foreign
that's how we do it welcome
happy holidays let's do it
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the podcast everybody
this is Eric Griffin
[Music]
today's a special episode I'm gonna
fully nerd and geek out Warzone 2 is
here I'm gonna tell you my journey
through playing video games uh finally
starting to stream on Twitch which I do
daily so check me out on Twitch
but for sure
[Music]
all right y'all welcome back to Griffin
with Griffin it's good to be here
how is everyone uh like I say welcome to
the show welcome to the show uh welcome
to Griffin with Griffin as you know this
is uh you can find my website
airgriffin.com with all my information
my tour dates and things like that
coming up please guys make sure you hit
the Subscribe share like button so you
can get notifications when I go live
which I usually do sometime on Tuesday
today was an exceptionally busy day I
don't know why I just I was wanted to do
it early in the morning but it just the
day got away from me you know it is what
it is
um so make sure you check out you know
you check me out on Twitch like I say
I'm there daily uh you know there it is
right there check me out on Twitch you
know you support me on Twitch you can
support me on be a YouTube member and
you can support me also on patreon if
you want you can also support me on
um Instagram subscribers now too they
even they even have that so there's all
different lines away if you're like yo
man I want to give you a little
something for what you do and then I'll
give give you a little extra how it
works like that I need to do more on my
patreon that's why patreon's not big but
I'm trying to figure out what to do
again I'm just by myself it's tough
schedule's heating up but shout out to
my producer Kristen who's been helping
me a lot with my ads and stuff like I
mean my um you know videos and stuff
like that so I hope you guys have been
checking that stuff out so check me out
there but also coming up this weekend
everybody I want to say Happy
Thanksgiving and now that you've done
with your Thanksgiving come check me out
at the Addison Improv Dallas Texas area
November 25th through the 27th you
tickets on airgrippen.com or you can go
to
improvtx.com and check me out
do it this week in Dallas
I will see you there
all right
I don't do that enough for all you
people that are always asking like what
are my show dates I got a bunch of stuff
into 2023 coming up so we got to get all
that out there so welcome back to the
podcast guys
um what's going on what is going on I
had a busy day did uh King and not
Kingdom the golden hour I even shot
gen to gen today that's my other podcast
with Matthew Espinosa shout out to him
you can check that out it's me and
Matthew discussing like
just discussing things from different
perspectives I'm 50 he's 25 and we get
that
and you know it is what it is here you
are with Griffin and once again as I
said last week I'll say again this week
you know this isn't necessarily A comedy
podcast if you're coming here for comedy
go watch me on the golden hour which
we're doing six episodes a month two on
patreon for free so go check me out and
go now I'm super funny there uh uh you
know you check me out even on other
podcasts I've been on tigerbelly bad
friends other things like that but here
this is a stream of Consciousness live
with Eric Griffin sometimes I'm funny
sometimes I'm just like giving you my
thoughts about what I think is going on
in the world which I think is also
important too you know I started to you
know I got enough people saying to me
like you know hey man is this a comedy
podcast and then I was like you know
what you're right what am I doing over
here pretending like I'm doing a comedy
podcast when I'm actually doing like you
know sometimes I get really serious
sometimes I like talking about certain
serious topics and this is where you
come to see that so I just want you to
know that from from jump as you're
listening so I don't want you to be
surprised if you're listening you're
like hey this guy seems pretty serious I
thought this was a comedy podcast
um you know it is what it is this is uh
from the mind of Griffin that's why we
riffing with Griffin so welcome I gotta
tell you something that happened like I
I don't know most of y'all have iPhones
I'm sure
so iPhone right I I downloaded this new
software right and then like I'm trying
to like you know they have this whole
widget thing you know widgets are like
you know like different apps have
different things it could be right on
the screen thank you send Jose for other
people listening a lot listening later
somebody just gave me a super chat on
YouTube so I'm thanking him so San Jose
sharkin thank you for the Super Chat I
appreciate you brother
um so I you know so I updated the
software on the phone so they have these
widgets and widgets are like you know
you could put the clock or you could put
like like I use United Airlines and so
like it could be right on your home
screen you know the flight time or like
PayPal or venmo you can like
everything's like these widgets so I put
this widget on my front page or my
iPhone and the whole thing went crazy
like I put it on the front page and all
my half my folders disappeared
like all the folders you have on the
front page maybe you have like social
media and then like you have all your
social media apps so for some reason it
blew out like five important folders and
just put the apps just it made like 10
home screens and all my apps were on the
screen I'm talking about years of
getting this right man you know what I
mean like you have like folders I have
like for my electric car I have a folder
for social media I have a folder for my
podcast I have a folder financials I
have a folder I have a folder for like
photos music uh you know tools Apple
things and I've put them all in perfect
places and I had it all ready to go new
software blows it all up man
so annoying like what is happening with
Apple man so I have no idea so if
anybody out there knows how to fix that
without having to reset the whole phone
you would think that you'd be able to
plug the phone in go right to like the
the I the the the folder with all the
settings that come up if you have a Mac
you know what I'm talking about like you
plug the fold in and when you open up
the folder like all these little uh
things you could do this should be like
home screen something
you know what I mean and it's not
so I don't know and I see people right
now talking on uh you know on the on the
chat right now
these guys are trying to talk about
Android Voice versus iPhone I mean it's
not even a question y'all
let's put a poll up iPhone
uh Android
all right
you know what I mean I don't even think
it's gonna even be close you know what
I'm saying ask the community
we'll do it like that you know and if
you have like also guys if you wanna
um a little little q a
you know what I'm saying
all right ask
you know oh this is I'll call this one
like this little section right here I'm
doing this live I'm so sorry for the
people listening later you know
oh we should have this up
you know that should always be I'm just
in case anybody wants to you know get
some advice you know what I mean so
grown man advice start q a so I always
have that there too
all right so anyways
welcome back to the show so yeah I don't
know if anybody knows how to do that but
I think one of the ways I found out
um one of the ways I found out to do it
is you have to
you know you just reset your phone from
backup you know which is like
it's like damn do I even want to do that
at this point now I don't keep anything
on my phone right do you are you keeping
things on your phone like there's
nothing I save on my phone like you know
I have the iCloud and I'm paying for
that like service where you get Apple TV
you get the news you get like apple
games you get like whatever that thing
is and there's like something like two
terabytes of iCloud that you can get so
I have like I know all my pictures and
videos and all the stuff from my phone
is right there
um you know it's in the uh
in in what you call it man and in my
iCloud so like I've changed my phone a
few times and I just kind of be like
okay whatever you know what I mean so I
don't know
I don't know
um
I don't know if it you know even even
does anything if it even means anything
like like what are you saving on your
phone these days I mean I remember that
used to be a big thing remember you get
a new phone and you're like oh man all
my pictures and it would just be this
whole thing and then it was like you had
the Bluetooth then it was like oh you
have to plug your phone into the
computer and that seemed a little shoddy
like you know it was like this whole
thing man I I don't know I think the
technology is like a lot better now but
but it's hard to stay
you know it's really hard to
it's hard to say
like what what
um
what the best best thing is oh here we
go I see what this is now I I didn't
know what was happening right here I
couldn't see the chat anymore all that
stuff but now I realize how you fix it
so sorry about that there we go yeah all
right yeah so if I want to go to the Q a
I go to the Q a if I want to see the
chat I see the chat
hey you know we'll start a war I mean I
know there's some Android nerds in the
thing right now I don't want nothing to
do with you Android people are like
twins and redheads that's the devil's
work
oh man
so I don't know it looks like it looks
like it's a heated pole though so we'll
see you know we'll see what we get out
of that right now wow how is Android
winning 55 well there there you go the
river with Griffin crowd is a bunch of
Android crazy people so that explains
that right there
uh
anyways
um
all right so today's episode guys I
wanted to go into like you know I wanted
to talk about gaming and stuff man I
wanted to I wanted to discuss
gaming and my my
journey through gaming my journey
through iPhone you know so you can like
see like where I've come from and I'm
not iPhone like when I started you know
my gaming my gaming career you know what
I mean
well you know what I I see the my green
screen is messing up I hate that I'm so
like I I'm so like OCD anal about the
green screen and I can see that it's not
right and I hate that so much
I don't know I guess I gotta let it go
right just let it go Griffin let it go
you know what I mean
um
so I started gaming a long time ago
right so you know because I'm like I
said you can catch me live on Twitch I
might go on for a little while after I
get off of this podcast but you know so
check me out live on Twitch here we go
from gaming I sometimes I sometimes do
it live on YouTube also on Eric Griffin
gaming you know but I've been gaming for
a while man like gaming is yeah I I
think the what I think the first system
I ever got was ColecoVision I don't know
if you guys even remember coleco Vision
but it was so clunky you know it had a
bunch of cables there was no wireless
controllers at the time and like you
know there's maybe a couple of buttons
on it with like a a really crazy
directional pad you know it had this
like weird
you know it was this weird directional
pad on it
um you know let me see if I can look it
up real Chris
coleco Vision there you go you know what
I mean and it was just like a weird
system man yeah wow look at that I
haven't seen that in so long let's see
if this works
yeah check out the coleco vision yeah
that was the first video game system I
ever had I wow that just that just looks
ancient now you know for the people
listening this looks like a a weird
phone keypad with numbers and it was
just like this weird clunky thing that
just the the technology wasn't all that
great
and you know and of course of course I
had an Atari you know remember the first
Atari game system the Atari 1200 or
Atari
um
you know and this this was the first
time like it really introduced like you
know like a joystick you know like this
was like oh you could still buy these
man they're charging 200 something
dollars for these damn things now man
but it was like the Atari and it had
like it had its first
um
it has it had its first like this was
the first time you saw like a like uh a
weird joystick with like one button I
mean look at that man when you when you
think about that that's that's how it
started you know in terms of like
in terms of like
buttons and stuff like isn't that crazy
like that's crazy to think that like it
was only one stick and it wasn't even
that easy to like hold you know it
wasn't even that easy to hold like it
hurt actually I remember it like being
like it would hurt your hand you know
what I mean I remember it being like not
very
um
not very easy to like maneuver through
it you know like you you'd be it'd be
like the it would hurt your thumb but it
was like that was like pretty amazing to
have like a system like that
you know uh so whatever the games are
and the games weren't even that good you
know you had like asteroids and like
pong you know and you just you know you
you'd even still play for hours back
then so I did have one of those as well
I did have a ColecoVision and all that
stuff uh clinical Vision Atari and then
it was like Nintendo 64 and then it was
like you know you got you you got like a
Genesis you know remember when the
Genesis came about that was like you
know you couldn't even believe that that
that this was happening I was like what
Genesis you know what I mean and it was
like
[Music]
um
I I like that's when like the games were
like okay this is some serious business
right here you know what I mean like you
had like basketball games and like
sports games and like stuff like that
and so I just remember that being like a
really big deal and so I I had all that
stuff I had the Nintendo 64. I had the
Genesis and then you got into then it
was like Xbox came out and then I was an
Xbox person for a long time I had a
Dreamcast too thank you Dreamcast was a
big one too we had we had to have a
Dreamcast
um and then like I say I became like an
Xbox person pretty pretty pretty early
on I was like I was I was Mr Xbox you
know I thought that was like uh I
thought that was the best one because
then it was like connected to Microsoft
and I had like you know because I had a
PC so you know you kind of understood
some of the language and some of the
like the things that they were doing uh
you know because like you know you could
have a accompanying app you know then
cell phones came about and you know you
know all this stuff was like interacting
and then it was like wireless
controllers and you know then it was
like online systems and then you started
like oh you could talk to people online
and it was like that was the game
process but I really wasn't like a huge
gamer though like when I first started
gaming the games I would play a lot
would be like I remember that game
Lakers Celtics on the dream it was
either on a Dreamcast or it was on a
Sega Genesis and me and my friends would
play that game at nauseum we would even
hold a draft
to see who got what team and then we
would do a tournament like we were
really into the sports games and then my
buddy Jeff and I we would just play 2K
then when the 2K series came out that
was our Jam we were just playing 2K all
the time it was so fun I never was in
the Madden because I'm not into football
like that I tried a little while but to
me when you're playing Madden if you
don't understand football it's like what
is this so I played Madden in those kind
of games
just briefly but it was for me it was
basketball
I used to like hockey games because it's
a fun video game I don't know if you
guys ever done that but you play like
hockey on a video game that's that
sucker is fun right and then I would
play and then it got into uh FIFA and
then you know how I I tell you how I got
into FIFA this is how I got into playing
FIFA I was on a Middle East comedy tour
with Bobby Lee and Sebastian
uh Maniscalco and shout out to Ahmed
Ahmed was the one that invited us on
this
um
he took us on these tours and so this is
the first time I'd met I'd seen Bobby at
the comedy store but we weren't really
friends we didn't really talk it was
just one of those things where it was
like he was Bobby and he was like he's
being batshit crazy since the first time
I ever met him so we're out in the
Middle East right and he's so bored he
buys uh Xbox out in the Middle East and
gets FIFA and we just started playing
FIFA in his hotel room in the hotel room
and we would just pay FIFA all the time
we he was carrying this Xbox all through
the Middle East and then with just the
three of us just that's all we would do
is play FIFA and he was really good at
it I didn't I'd never played it before
so we you know that was like some fun
times I always remember those times and
then like you know just doing comedy and
that's the first time I think Bobby
actually watched me do comedy and he was
just like whoa this guy's funny and you
know it was like it was
if you know Bobby Bobby always thinks
he's not doing well so like he was
having like a he thought he was having a
tough time with his crowd you know his
middle eastern people you know and I go
up there and I murder you know and so
now he's all like what you know what I
mean and so he was like who's this guy
and so because of that I think I earned
his respect but on that trip and then he
opened up and we became really good
friends
um
so
it is what it is and so I started
playing and after that I started playing
FIFA all the time so then I started
buying FIFA every year
13 14 15. FIFA 15 I think was the best
version of the game and then they ruined
it then they keep they keep coming and I
just I actually I'm not interested only
reason why I bought FIFA a couple times
now is because I'm streaming and I know
people like watching that content but
it's just it's they keep changing it you
keep changing it so then cut to I
started playing this game Destiny
another game I played a lot with Bobby
and Steve by the way Bobby and I
and Steve we would play Destiny till
seven o'clock in the morning all night
just yelling at each other and like come
on get the thing we were doing all these
missions and and all these things to
like rank up guns and collect loot it
was like this Destiny was like the first
time they capitalized on this sort of
like Casino feeling in a video game
that's the first time I experienced it
and I'm sure the other games may have
done it but Destiny was like the game
and I played Destiny's like I I feel
like damn near eight years I feel like
Destiny was my game like I every time I
didn't want to play it anymore I would
go back and it would suck me back in man
and so Destiny was the game but then
what started to happen was this is what
starts to happen with those type of
games you know when you when say a first
a new DLC comes out and it's like the
mission is to like you have to like you
get a certain gun and you have to do
certain mission to rank up the gun and
then and then after that there's no
purpose there's no there's nothing to
keep you there and then the multiplayer
aspect of Destiny like the you know
controls it's like you're playing six on
six against other teams and you have to
do you know you're fighting against each
other so they might have an objective
like one of them is called control
in uh Call of Duty is called domination
so there's like a flag it's like Capture
the Flag so your team when your team is
on the flag the color of the flag
changes to your team's color and then
you know you have to protect it or get
it so they have a bunch of objectives
like that in these multiplayer games but
nobody follows the objective because
it's just all about killing people you
just find someone you get them you know
and then it just becomes about getting
no stats in a multiplayer dimension of
it becomes stale and boring after a
while it's just you know it's hard and
then the other thing about Destiny that
made it like where I had to stop playing
it became super hard super sweaty
like the people that were playing were
so good at the game it became like it
wasn't fun for the common player like
the average Joe player it wasn't you
know it wasn't fun to play so you know
I just
it just it's just one of these things
where you just go I I stopped playing it
and then I started getting into so then
Call of Duty I never played Call of Duty
before I never played Call of Duty
until
the pandemic came like right but it was
actually it was actually right before
the pandemic
Call of Duty whatever number it was came
out and they came out with this game
called The Black Ops
now at the time
fortnite was becoming a huge thing
and Pub G became a huge game and these
are Battle Royale games so for the
people that don't know what it is and
the people that do know forgive me I'm
doing the best I can for the people that
don't understand it or just listen a
battle royale is
a big huge multiplayer game where say 50
to 100 people depending on the game
whatever the number is let's say it's
100 people they drop in on a map okay
now the map has
a circle of inbound Circle A big one a
huge one and that circle is closing
slowly
and what happens is it forces you to go
to the center of that Circle and whoever
is left standing wins
Call of Duty Call of Duty Call of Duty
is a perfect game actually I'm sorry
Battle Royale mode is a perfect game
because it's a forced objective that you
get what you want the point of it is you
know you want to go around and pick up
stats and kill a bunch of people and
rank up a bunch of guns but at the same
time there is an objective that has a
sweet ending
yeah I mean just when you win a battle
royale match man you feel like the top
of the world because you're like yes I
survived a hundred people or whatever it
is and then the game started to see the
game people like fortnite for instance
they started to go oh wow people love
this
and now they go they love it and they
also love different colors on their guns
and they love different out the
characters to have on different outfits
and and so they found a way to really
monetize it in a way so they go here's a
free game have this game for free it's a
it's really a mobile it's like from your
mobile phone it's really that mobile
phone
um you know way of doing it you know
that's like Candy Crush and all these
kinds of games we're making so much
money because people just kept playing
and playing the plane and they were like
I want to buy gems and I want to buy so
people in-game purchases became the
thing to the tune of a fortnight Call of
Duty they're making like a billion
dollars man you know it's craziness and
then there's at any particular time a
game like
um fortnite has like over three million
people playing it at all times and then
people are just buying skins and then so
they have so much money then they're
buying the rights to things so like
fortnite by the rights to like Star Wars
and so you could play as Darth Vader or
they'll buy like Raiders of the Lost Ark
rights and so now that your Indiana
Jones or whatever the hot thing is out
at the time these companies are now
competing to be like hey play with this
character whatever is hot right now it's
it's amazing uh but my point is that
system of Battle Royale is absolutely
perfect so I was playing Call of Duty
Black Ops for a little while
it's a really hard game that called it's
really hard because here's what happens
to you have to remember you have to wait
for the game to load the game loads you
drop in and if you die you have to start
all over and then you have to go back
out load again so it's a tough game and
Black Ops was really tough and so then I
Call of Duty comes out and they come out
with a game called warzone
and Warzone was spectacular I absolutely
loved it then the pandemic hit and then
I found a reason to sit here
be on Twitch monetize bring free content
out to people
um it is so great like the war zone and
then so it's the city it was like it was
called verdance and you know they had it
was a downtown area there was a uh you
know there was a quarry area it was this
huge map and you know this the battle it
was just going you know the circle just
keeps closing and you're fighting with
people you're playing with your friends
and then there's like kill comms which
means like when you when you kill
someone their their mic turns on for a
second so they're saying all kinds of
stuff and it gets toxic man it does it
gets racist and rude and whatever but
it's part of the game you know and so I
played war zone now for three years
accumulating wins I have 300 Victory
victories in war zone and I have like
282 victories in this the Resurgence now
what is Resurgence so this is the next
evolution of war zone that this to me is
a perfect game so people that like
multiplayer and what happens in a
multiplayer game is you just keep dying
and coming back so you die you come back
you die you come back it's just going on
and on and on and so you know people get
50 kills and they get 40 deaths and it's
just running around this map you know
ranking up guns and you know getting
experience points for whatever the game
wants you to do so you have multiplayer
so they took multiplayer the aspect of
dying and be able to come back right
away and they added the Battle Royale of
the circle closing and they called it
Resurgence so what happens with
Resurgence is you drop in
and you know with a teammate whatever
and at first they did it like this you
you have a teammate they didn't have
solos at the time and by the way I love
playing Warzone solo like to to me verse
150 people and I finished first and the
end it is a gratifying feeling I love it
so that they did with Resurgence is that
you had to play with a teammate so it's
like two three four people you have a
quad Duos trios quads right and so like
if as long as as long as someone on your
team was alive after you died you
immediately uh landed back into the war
zone so that was and so you had the
multiplayer aspect plus the war zone it
caught fire it was the most popular game
it was lovely
so I've been playing Warzone for a while
now my problem my problem
with um war zone is not the game itself
it's the people that make it and the
choices that they make
and that's where my issue has always
been now for three years it's a perfect
game that they keep ruining they keep
getting in their own way you know they
keep making things like there's there'll
be a meta gun meaning it's a gun that is
like the best gun in the game and and
then all the pros are using it so
everybody's using it and you can't beat
it and so you had you had to deal with
that so then it became a thing where I
have to get this meta gun it's the only
gun I can use because everybody else is
using it and sometimes they made it
where it was like super overpowered and
then now everybody had to use it it just
became frustrating they kept changing
things in the map they kept blowing up
downtown and making it ruining it and
then they you know they but then they
sometimes they did some good stuff they
added nakatomi Tower from die hard so
that was a great addition and then they
just kept changing the map and tinkering
with the guns and then adding perks and
taking them away and then adding stupid
missions to the game that was like
Pointless Stuff and you know it's like
they keep trying to get in their way
they keep trying to ruining they keep
trying to ruin this great game to me
it's like a hot chick with bad breath
you know you're just like oh damn you're
dope but can you not talk you know it's
like they just find a way to ruin it and
that's what they did so cut to now after
playing it for three years and then
there was some sweaty stuff in there and
it was the the pros the the Nerds these
sweats they found they found little
cheats in the game they found little
little exploits like slide canceling so
they found ways to like Zip all over the
map they found ways to take advantage of
the aim assist with this snap uh snipe
shooting they you know they found little
things and so it was a it was a causing
an issue with like the average player
was like well I'm not having fun because
I can never beat you know one of these
guys even though Warzone I I'm I haven't
decided if I like one or two better yet
right
because they took out that stuff but it
actually made it a way harder game I
mean one thing I really enjoyed about
Warzone something like they didn't all
do it all wrong
they would add things like a thing
called a dead silence it's like a perk
that you pick up this thing and you
activate it and your character makes
zero noise so you can sneak up on
somebody and kill them that levels the
playing field those kind of things level
the playing field and the ttk levels the
playing field ttk is time to kill the
ttk meaning like so if it's a game where
it's a longer time to kill that benefits
the more skilled player because then the
more skilled player is going to be out
there you know you know you're trying to
kill them and you can't because they're
more skilled than you you lower the ttk
then you actually have a chance if you
get some good shots in to beat anybody
so I feel like you know that would they
had a perfect ttk as opposed to like
Apex which I just I don't like it I
can't play it the shooting and
everything the mechanics of it I don't
like I think the war zone the Call of
Duty mechanics are perfect you know and
then you have a game like Battlefield
who they came out biggest bust ever they
come out with this game and they don't
make a battle royale they think they
understand it was the stupidest decision
ever the people that make Battlefield
you guys whoever made that idiot
decision not to make a battle royale
should be fired okay
should be fired because if Battlefield
had a bat a battle royale we would all
be playing Battlefield because the
shooting mechanics are similar the the
scenery looks better you could blow up
buildings you could put holes in
buildings the mechanics of the gun
everything is like it was different
enough and I believe the mechanics
better that you know we would have been
playing that so cut to now war zone two
and as a special treat I'm going to
actually
I'm going to actually show you what it
looks like so if you're listening right
now you know you can still listen you
know listen but when you get a chance
you might want to go over to
you might want to go over to the uh
um the YouTube at riffing with Griffin
at Roofing with Griffin now they got the
new ads uh and check out
um you know
what I got going on so you can see you
can see because I'm showing it on the
screen so this is I'm this is I'm
showing you on my PlayStation right now
I'm going to show you PlayStation uh war
zone two
um
here we go so Warzone 2 you know made by
Activision Treyarch and all this so now
you know it was people been waiting the
anticipation because something that I'll
say that kind of like Master war zone up
the first one is they had this great map
verdanced I Love Her Dance I miss it I
wish I could still play it I believe
it's coming to the mobile
but they got rid of her dance and they
added this map called Caldera this sort
of like Hawaiian Pacific
1950s huts and World War II guns and and
this stupid map that was just a big hill
to a volcano with no real Like You Know
cover no hiding place no downtown no
modern buildings
it was just a dumb map
didn't like it at all I started playing
Resurgence I didn't really like the
Resurgence at first because you have to
play with other people and I like to
play solo a lot and then they added
solos so they did so they added solo
Resurgence and they found a perfect way
to do it so if you die and you come back
there's a timer so you get like 15
seconds 20 seconds uh if you stay alive
within that time then you you're you get
another Resurgence but if you die within
that your game is done you're done so
they found a way and I love it uh so
much okay so cut to now you know they
had the Caldera I hated it I wanted to
get to 300 victories I got to 300
victories in Caldera I did it done with
it never playing it again
then cut to just recently here is war
zone two war zone 2 is here and I want
to give you my review
what's going on here an update is
required you must
um oh man what is going on here just oh
you know I I find that I'm having an
issue with the PlayStation that when I
open Warzone after the uh when you put
it to rest like when you put it to rest
it doesn't something doesn't work right
when you when you have it in rest mode I
don't know if anybody else is having
that issue but then when you try to open
up it'll say it's not downloaded it'll
say you don't own the game or something
then you restart and then all of a
sudden it works
um
you know what I mean so I see somebody
who's disagreeing with me I don't I
don't I don't I don't know if it's
respectful what he's
what he's saying about how he said it
doesn't seem very respectful
uh
I don't know what anyways I don't know
what you guys are talking about right
there but you know stop being rude
especially talking about my friends
um
okay let's see what happens here I think
there might was there an update let's
see if there's an update I think it
should have updated on its own though I
I I should have checked this oh
oh it's updating oh that's annoying I'm
in the middle of a podcast PlayStation
but it goes pretty I have pretty good
internet so it's gonna download pretty
fast I hope this isn't messing with the
stream though because that's sometimes
what happens too like you're downloading
and it messes with the Stream So anyways
yeah but actually actually this is the
PlayStation that Brendan shop got me and
shout out to battle Beaver by the way
let's give a little battle Beaver shout
out uh they they I got this custom
controller made for the PlayStation and
it's pretty good now I've been an Xbox
guy for a long time and I gotta say so
when I'm talking about the differences
between these two controllers you know
when you have like Let Me Go full screen
um
the differences between these
controllers so this is an Xbox Elite
controller and this is a PlayStation now
I really like the elite controller for
for I've tried different things I had a
scuff controller and it's okay I had a
battle Beaver one which I still use on
the road like I have a little Xbox I
take on the road with me but this Elite
controller is my favorite it's sturdy
it's heavy it hooks it interacts with
the Xbox software not the best you know
and so I really like that I like this
but I have to say that when I'm playing
war zone
I'm enjoying the PlayStation controller
even more
um I don't know why that is but I really
enjoy the PlayStation controller I I
like that it's a little bit bigger I
like that the buttons are straight
across you know like the buttons are
like as opposed to like in different
spots on the on the on the Xbox
controller so it gives me a different
movement that uh when I'm playing Xbox
um I'm playing PlayStation I feel like
it has a better a better feel to it so I
I really like that you know I really
like that let me see if I need to update
let me see if I need to update my
controller seems like the controller is
good it doesn't seem like it needs an
update you never know you know what I
mean yeah I never know
uh yeah it doesn't look like it needs oh
let's see do this one controller up to
date okay let's make sure all right okay
here we go all right so I don't have the
sound on the game either because I don't
want to add the sound so let's now look
at
so as I was saying
you know they came out with war zone two
so this is going to be I'm gonna finish
the podcast off with my Warzone 2 review
and I thank you guys for being here
wait did anybody have let me see if
there was any okay no I don't nobody
really said anything on that so I'm not
gonna is this and that and then the poll
let me see how the poll ended up wow so
the you guys are such trolls
[Laughter]
so that I Android B iPhone you trolls I
hate you guys
[Laughter]
okay so here we are guys I'm gonna give
you my review of war zone two this is my
review of war zone 2
as seen on riffing with Griffin for when
I put this over on Eric Griffin gaming
so there he is right there Call of Duty
so my first thoughts about war zone 2 is
oh um
I don't like the UI that's the user
interface I think the user interface is
terrible not a fan of this at all
you know it's like
and it may be it could be something
about like not being used to it but I
just it's not that man it's like you
know
you know like to to find your friends
you know you have to go over to this
window right and then you know you got
to go to Social and then when you're at
Social it's like party settings or like
invite people to party it's so weird you
can't find people you know it's it's
like a such a weird user interface you
press the control button and then it's
like so you have this thing where it's
like you have parties I know I'm in the
way but right it's right right here you
know you have like this all on the right
this thing opens up where it's like game
channel then you have your own channel
you can have then you have like this is
where the whispers are from people
sending you messages and it's just it's
complicated and confusing and you want
the every man to be able to like just
figure this out easy man and I just I
just don't like the unit user interface
face at all all they finally got stats
oh my stats are terrible because I just
started playing oh they don't have the
the multi they have they don't have the
um war zone stats yet
so
but you know so then you have this
interface okay so now it's time to like
you if you're gonna go play a game you
know what I mean so let's say if like
let's say I'm gonna go play war zone so
you go to war zone
so when you're in The War Zone menu it
starts with these you know all the all
the the menus are down on the bottom
right here the different games you can
play Battle Royale quads Duos trios
unhinged trios which is some weird game
where it's the Battle Royale but because
they have one of the best additions to
the game ever
proximity chat meaning if somebody is
like 50 yards in the game away from you
their mics turn on it's hot mics and you
guys are talking with each other it
makes for some really interesting
gameplay and really great clips for the
internet
um I'm always concerned that it's going
to be like super toxic but people have
actually been I haven't experienced a
like a major like issue of somebody
being rude and disrespectful racist or
homophobic or you know that kind of
nonsense people like to say you know for
the most part it's been like regular Cod
[ __ ] talk which I appreciate so that's
what unhinged trios is so this is
basically the menus for that now the
confusing menu now is the gun menu okay
oh my goodness so like you have your
loadouts and then they have this thing
called the gunsmith so here you are you
can select your guns so you have assault
rifles battle rifles SMGs shotguns lmgs
Mark some natural snipers and melee
weapons right so you say you want to
pick a assault rifle so you go to
assault rifle and and here's the
different versions of this same gun and
it's so confusing it's really confusing
to figure out what they what this even
means man you know like so so now
let me go down to another Loadout that I
haven't done anything with uh let's say
this one right here so you select so
let's say you're going to come here
you're going to select a gun you know uh
let's say I want to put a battle rifle
here you know so you you pick this
battle rifle right and then you go to
the gunsmith so the gunsmith is pretty
nice looking the gunsmith looks good you
know you have like the different things
you could do you put the barrels on or
whatever it is like that you know so
let's say I want to put a barrel on I
put this Barrel on and then they have
this you know
um but then they have this part just the
confusing part so this is called the
receiver and then there's different
versions of this gun within this class
so this gun is called the latch man and
so you have a Latchman AR then you have
this Latchman uh uh submachine gun then
there's a Latchman long range
marksman's rifle then you have another
AR version and you have like you know
another sub making me subversion so when
you're ranking it you have to rank up
all these levels and there's like a tree
it's really confusing are one of the
other best things I think they've added
to the game one of the great things is
this gun tuning so each attachment now
you have you could go and you go tuning
once you have it ranked all the way up
and now you can adjust the stats to how
you like it so on this one let's say I
want to have better aim walking speed
meaning like while I'm with my gun my
character while I'm aiming down sight my
character is going to be able to move
faster or I want the gun to have more
recoil steadiness you pick between the
two you can keep it in the middle or now
I could just move it up let's say I want
more recoil steadiness and let's say I
want more uh aim down sight speed so the
the how fast a gun goes up to to shoot
so maybe I say I want damage range on
this right and so now you you you have
that those settings and then you could
go another great addition to the game
that I really love is this firing range
so now you could put all the attachments
you want on the gun and now you could go
test it out okay now you can go test it
out so for instance this gun I'm using
right now is uh the the marksman's rifle
version of the gun so I think that that
is a really great addition to the game
kudos to them for that you know
so I really I really enjoy that so again
you know if you want to come here and
that's the battle rifle version of the
gun so you want to come to the AR here's
the AR version of the gun you know and
then you know you go to your gunsmith
you know you put your you know and then
and again you're ranking up all this
stuff that's why the multiplayer is uh
you know kind of important to play
um
you know I'm not a big fan of
playing multiplayer usually but I played
multiplayer because I wanted to rank up
the guns before the game came out you
know so you just put all this stuff on
here and for instance you know you could
tune everything so recoil smoothness or
aim down sight I prefer Rico I prefer
anything that's going to help the gun
shoot faster this was bullet velocity
over aim stability I would go I would
lean towards aim stability with that you
know under barrels so you know you get
an under Barrel they tell you they have
these like pros and cons there so you
can really spend a lot of time trying to
figure out what you want your gun to do
like you know what I mean like uh how
you want your gun to to to perform so I
really like those things you know I
think that's a good addition to the game
you know so you can only put five
attachments on don't like that one thing
I liked about Vanguard
um Call of Duty the last one with last
war zone when Vanguard came out is the
Vanguard guns had 10 attachments I think
they need to go back to that okay I
really I think they need to go back to
that so you know so once you again so
once you have the gun set up the way you
want then you go over here to the to the
gun range and you like you figure it out
you go oh I think this is like so then
you're testing it out you know and then
they have the things moving this is a
great addition to the game you can even
Mount you know what I mean so you know
and then if you don't now here's
something I think they need to add so
right here I think you should be able to
go to the gunsmith right here you know
but they're not letting you do that
which I don't like you should be able to
go to the gunsmith adjust it and then
come right back to the firing range but
no the way they have it now is you have
to actually leave the gunsmith I guess
that's not too bad I guess that's the
same thing right there I think they
actually they just changed that
so now I can just go and be like what do
I want for my gun you know uh like do I
want Flinch resistance or aim down sight
so that's how you can like recover your
aim down side that you lost when you
change these other things you know so
again I like uh the the gun system
um so then it's like now it's just about
if you like to game play and I'll show
you a little bit of the gameplay and
then I'm gonna get out of here but I
really appreciate you guys watching the
show today
um and then the people that are
listening you know you might want to you
know if you're into this kind of stuff
if you're not I totally get it you
probably tuned out already probably not
even going this far
[Laughter]
you know and then you know you have the
drop in you know so then you have like
you know you have your daily missions
and stuff like that and so then I'll
show you guys the map and then uh you
know we'll get out of here but um I like
overall I like the game I think it's a
much harder game I think that the
movement is better for like that every
man the the average gamer
um it is difficult I think the ttk is
too high right now I mean like just too
fast right now like even with three
plates on you get wrecked so I think
they need to there's no getting away so
I think they need to fix that a little
bit don't go too crazy with it but I
think the ttk needs to go up I think
that the AR guns are trash Ash I think
that they they all don't shoot long
distance in the same way that the last
game so I think they need to adjust that
because right now the best guns in the
game are
SMGs sniper rifles and even some
shotguns at close range because of how
deadly the damage is uh so
you know I don't know uh and then you
have like different characters I am
gonna miss my character I had a
character that looked just like me they
don't have that in the game you know so
you have like different operators you
can pick you know it's very ethnic you
know they're trying to like you know
there's very diverse
you know and then they have like you
know they have the battle pass system
now it's like this new map of the battle
pass system you know you could customize
your calling cards your emblems your
vehicles overall I enjoy the game I do
it's much harder it's more challenging I
think with a lot of gameplay a lot of
reps I think that I'll I'll probably be
like oh I I'll figure it out and I'll
start playing better at this point right
now I only have one Victory and you
could check that Victory out at Eric
Griffin gaming on YouTube I just put
that video up today of the victory I got
with my boy Brian yesterday we finally
got a war zone Victory so after many
attempts Warzone 2 Victory so you should
uh check that out um I am gonna do more
talking about the games on my Eric
Griffin gaming channel I'll just record
them live on Twitch and then I'll put
them up on my gaming channel so if you
want to subscribe to my gaming channel
pop on over to Eric Griffin gaming and
make sure you give me a
a a follow right there too so
let me let me the proximity chat is
always on so you can see that right
there
um I don't want you I don't want to like
have people talking and stuff right now
I don't even have the sound on but this
is the map man and the map looks really
great it's a really great sort of uh
combination of Caldera and verdance from
the the first year so you have some
Mountain areas over here you have a high
area then but you also have a very low
uh area with a lot of buildings you know
you could swim now that's another thing
another beautiful addition to the game
is a swimmings let me show you guys what
that looks like you can even fall into
the water oh you die oh I badly flop
died oh normally you don't die so there
is fall damage now there's fall damage
um
so that's kind of cool too so you don't
necessarily break your legs all the time
Wars on one you would break your legs
you fall 15 meters you break your legs
now you lose Health you lose plates you
can keep going so that's a really cool
addition to the game too so it's um
it's pretty fun so I will say if you're
into
you know war zone if you're into battle
royale games I think this is a great
game I think this game is if Pub G and
and um
I think a war zone and I think it's like
pubg and Battlefield had a baby with
more with war zone mechanics that's what
this game is that's what this game is
and in Warzone one I used to love to
drop in in downtown and so I'm gonna
drop into downtown again even though
it's not even in the map and I used to
love this I used to there was a tower
that the kids that watched me play they
called it Griff Tower because I dropped
there all the time so this is now the
new Griff Tower over here in downtown Al
mazara City or whatever you know some
made up location so but anyways guys you
know it's a pretty it's a pretty uh
pretty fun game
um again I I do I do recommend it you
know I'm not I'm not going to be a
complete hater I I really get if you
watch me on Twitch I really go in on the
game a lot and the reason is is because
I think that the game
it's a great game and they're getting in
their own way trying to ruin the game
and I cannot stand that you know what I
mean I can't stand it so
yeah guys I appreciate you guys watching
the podcast you know
um
you know what we do is time for the the
the the the
what do you call it rap recap
and I'm gonna do it while I'm playing
all right y'all so thanks for watching
Griffin with Griffin and remember I'll
be in Dallas this weekend Happy
Thanksgiving also everybody I know I
didn't even say anything Thanksgiving
stuff but I want to say Happy
Thanksgiving make sure you subscribe and
share and thank you for watching Griffin
Griffin once again once again
the rap recap
Call of Duty you get clapped
dropping in
with no guns but I'm stacked
this is good power
podcast be an hour
you'll need a shower
[Music]
I love this game it's going in the Hall
of Fame
I'm not tame
sometimes my rap be lame
but I'm the best in the game
putting other parts to shame
[Music]
the right recap
[Music]
step up and get slapped
thanks for watching y'all
you can catch me now on
twitch and I will be playing Call of
Duty probably this same game so if you
go over to Call of Duty right now you
will see me in this game
and thank you for watching
ripping with Griffin